[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
hallo zusammen und herzlich Willkommen
zu Tatort Deutschland ich bin Stefan
Netzeband auszugsweise wieder hier für
unser weibliches krimipersonal anwesend
und mit mir am Mikrofon ist Mirko
Kasimir und wir erzählen heute eine
Weihnachtsgeschichte
aber so ganz und gar nicht zu stille
Nacht heilige Nacht passt denn das Fest
der Liebe wird für eine Familie in West
Virginia zur Hölle und hinterlässt Asche
Verzweiflung und ein quälendes bis heute
ungelöstes Rätsel
[Musik]
das ist so eine Geschichte die einen
echt verfolgt weil sie ja klar so
schrecklich ist und weil sie aber diese
unbeantworteten Fragen aufwirft ich
meine okay irgendwie wirft fast jedes
Verbrechen für mich unbeantwortete
Fragen auf meistert dass sie nach Motiv
und selbst wenn das Hut damit also das
wäre was geklärt ist bleibt bei mir oft
eben dieses warum und wenn ein Mörder
vor Gericht 1000 mal in allen Details
erklärt warum er einen anderen Menschen
getötet hat und wenn mir Psychologen das
in allen Details auseinanderklamüsern
ich kriege das trotzdem manchmal nicht
im Kopf wie man sowas tun kann aber um
die Frage geht es heute nicht oder nicht
nur auf jeden Fall hier gibt es so viele
Fragen und die erste und größte ist was
der ist schon wirklich seltsam
normalerweise erzählen wir ja hier von
morgen manchmal von den Führungen
manchmal von Menschen die spurlos
verschwinden aber bei dem Fall von dem
wir heute erzählen wissen wir nicht um
welche Art von Verbrechen es sich
handelt oder ob es sich überhaupt um
einen Verbrechen handelt ob wir von Mord
sprechen oder Entführung von einem Mafia
Mord einer Racheaktion von Faschisten
oder der aus dem Ruder gelaufenen
Kundenakquise eines Wahnsinnigen
Versicherungsvertreters vielleicht geht
es aber auch um eine Verschwörung von
Polizei und Feuerwehr oder um ein
Familiendrama wir wissen nur dass in
dieser unseligen Nacht fünf Kinder aus
dem Schoß ihrer Familie gerissen werden
und nie wieder auftauchen Mirko erzähl
uns die Geschichte der sodass
[Musik]
1895 kommt in Thule auf Sardinien ein
Junge namens jordjos zur Welt mit gerade
einmal 13 Jahren und in Begleitung eines
älteren Bruders verlässt er Italien in
Richtung Amerika
wie Millionen vor und nach ihm setzt er
seinen Fuß zuerst auf Alice Island die
kleine Insel nahe dem Hafen von New York
City
[Musik]
warum er Italien verlassen hat ist nicht
ganz klar Giorgio Sardou der sich von
nun an George Sauda nennt spricht nicht
über seine alte Heimat wahrscheinlich
war es wie bei so vielen die Flucht aus
der Armut und die Hoffnung auf den
amerikanischen Traum und der Junge
George macht sich sehr schnell mit
großem Fleiß und großem Ehrgeiz daran
diesen Traum dann auch wahrzumachen er
arbeitet in Pennsylvania für die
Eisenbahn findet dann einen Job als
LKW-Fahrer ins Mutters in West Virginia
und gründet schließlich seine eigene
Firma ein Speditionsunternehmen das
anfangs Baustellen mit Sand und Schotter
beliefert und später auch Kohle
transportiert und er lernt Jenny kennen
die Tochter eines Ladenbesitzers ins
Mittlers Jenny stand ebenfalls aus
Italien die beiden verlieben sich
gründen eine Familie sie bauen in der
Nähe von feiert will ebenfalls in West
Virginia ein schickes zweistöckiges
fast eine Art Fachwerkhaus mit dicken
Holzbalken
1923 wird das erste von insgesamt zehn
Kinder geboren das Geschäft von George
floriert die soll das steigen auf und
ein städtischer Beamter beschreibt sie
als eine der respektabelsten
Mittelstandsfamilien in der Gegend eine
amerikanische Erfolgsgeschichte bis zum
24 Dezember
1945 die Familie ist zusammengekommen um
den Weihnachtsabend zu feiern Mutter
Vater und neun Kinder nur der
zweitälteste Sohn fehlt er ist 1943 zu
Armee gegangen hat im Zweiten Weltkrieg
gekämpft und ist noch immer beim Militär
der älteste Sohn ist 22 die jüngste
Tochter Silvia gerade zwei Jahre alt
eine riesenfamilie und ich könnte mir
vorstellen dass es einigermaßen
turbulent zugegangen sein muss obwohl
das richtige Fest noch bevorsteht denn
in den USA feiert man üblicherweise am
25 Dezember der 24 Dezember ist eher ein
besinnlicher Abend mit der Familie ohne
Geschenke aber die 19-Jährige Marian die
in einem kleinen Laden in fate will
arbeitet hat dort für ihre jüngeren
Schwestern Martha Jenny und Betty die 12
58 Jahre alt sind Spielzeuge besorgt und
als große Überraschung schenkt sie ihn
schon an diesem Abend dieses Spielzeuge
die Mädchen sind völlig begeistert und
bitten ihre Eltern ausnahmsweise länger
aufbleiben zu können und damit spielen
zu können die Mutter lässt sich breit
schlagen die Mädchen dürfen auf bleiben
aber nur solange ihre Brüder Maurice 14
und Luis 9 auch noch wach sind
und nur wenn die beiden versprechen die
Kühe einzusperren und die Hühner zu
füttern bevor sie selbst ins Bett gehen
und natürlich versprechen sie das gegen
10 Uhr schnappt sich Mutter Jenny die
kleine Silvia und geht mit ihr nach oben
ins Schlafzimmer der Vater der älteste
Sohn John und der 16-Jährige George
Junior schlafen da schon tief und fest
Weihnachten hin Weihnachten her sie
haben den ganzen Tag in der
Familienfirma gearbeitet und sind
tatsächlich bald nach dem Abendbrot
schon ins Bett gegangen
es ist 0:30 Uhr als das schrillen des
Telefons Jenny die Mutter aus dem Schlaf
reist sie quält sich aus dem Bett und
geht die einzige Treppe hinunter ins
Erdgeschoss zum Telefon also für die
jüngeren unter uns so war das damals
noch ein Telefon ein Telefon muss man
betonen im ganzen Haus und das hängt
natürlich an einer Strippe es war
schwarz und globig wahrscheinlich aus
Bakelit eine Art Vorläufer des Plastiks
ich sag das nur für den Fall dass ich
jemand wundert warum sie z.B kein
Telefon neben dem Bett liegen hat die
Mutter geht also die Treppe nach unten
und hebt den Hörer ab eine fremde Frau
ist am anderen Ende und fragt Jenny nach
einem Namen den Sie noch nie gehört hat
im Hintergrund hört sie stimmengewehr
und Gelächter offenbar findet eine Party
statt
Jenny sagte Frau am Telefon dass sie
wohl die falsche Nummer gewählt haben
muss daraufhin lacht die Frau seltsam so
erzählt es Jenny zumindest später sie
liegt auf als sie zurück ins Bett gehen
will fällt ihr auf dass das Licht noch
brennt und die Vorhänge nicht zugezogen
sind das ist eigentlich die Aufgabe der
Kinder wenn sie länger als die Eltern
aufbleiben marien die 14-Jährige schläft
auf der Couch die anderen Kinder sind
nicht mehr im Wohnzimmer Jenny vermutet
also dass sie wohl nach oben gegangen
sind in ihr Zimmer auf dem Dachboden und
zu schlafen sie zieht die Vorhänge zu
lösch das Licht und geht wieder ins Bett
gegen 1 Uhr wird sie erneut geweckt
etwas ist auf das Dach des Hauses
gefallen und dann heruntergerollt Jenny
lauscht doch es bleibt ruhig und so
schläft sie wieder ein bis sie eine
halbe Stunde später endgültig aufwacht
der Geruch von Rauch hat sie geweckt
Jenny springt aus dem Bett es brennt sie
greift die kleine Silvia und rüttelt
ihren Mann George wach der Weg die
beiden anderen Kinder dann rennen sie
die Treppe runter und entkommen mit
Marion die unten geschlafen hat aus dem
brennenden Haus der Vater und die beiden
Söhne Rennen wieder hinein um das
Dachgeschoss zu erreichen doch die
Flammen versperren ihnen den Weg barfuß
klettert schon der Fassade hoch und
schlägt ein Fenster des Dachbodens ein
wobei er sich tiefe Schnitte am Arm zu
fügt
doch er kann die Kinder nicht erreichen
er und seine Söhne Rennen zur anderen
Seite des Hauses dort steht immer eine
große Leiter an die Mauer gelehnt mit
der könnten Sie mit etwas Glück zu den
drei Mädchen und zwei Jungen gelangen
die im Dachgeschoss gefangen sein müssen
aber die Leiter ist weg
der Vater hat eine andere Idee zwei
seiner Lastwagen stehen auf dem
Grundstück wenn er einen davon an das
Haus fährt könnten Sie vielleicht
darüber an der richtigen Stelle ins
Dachgeschoss klettern und die Kinder
retten er klettert hinter das Lenkrad
des ersten LKW er springt nicht an dabei
hat er am Vortag noch einwandfrei
funktioniert dort ganz zum zweiten
Lastwagen aber auch der springt nicht an
obwohl auch er gerade noch funktioniert
hat unterdessen rennt Marian zum Haus
eines Nachbarn um die Feuerwehr zu rufen
ein Auto auf der nahegelegenen Straße
sieht die Flammen ebenfalls und versucht
von einer nahegelegenen Taverne aus
die Feuerwehr zu erreichen
[Musik]
aber sie haben keinen Erfolg hilflos
müssen Jenny und Jobs oder ihre Töchter
Marian und die kleine Silvia sowie die
beiden Söhne George Junior und John mit
ansehen wie das Haus innerhalb von 35
bis vielleicht 45 Minuten vollständig
abbrennt und zusammenstürzt Marcel Jenny
Betty Louis und Maurice sind im Haus
zurückgeblieben oder auch nicht
die Feuerwehr trifft erst am nächsten
Morgen ein gegen 7 Uhr oder 9 Uhr die
Berichte widersprechen sich da aber auf
jeden Fall erst Stunden nach Ausbruch
des Feuers und auch Stunden nachdem man
endlich doch den Chef der Polizei
telefonisch erreicht hat aber wir
befinden uns in einer amerikanischen
Kleinstadt am Weihnachtsabend 1945 es
gibt keinen zentralen Notruf die Männer
müssen mühselig über eine Telefonkette
zusammengerufen werden oder indem man
von Haus zu Haus geht und Feuerwehrchef
Morris kann das Feuerwehrauto nicht
fahren und muss auf jemanden warten der
das für ihn übernimmt weil ich bin froh
dass ich feuerwehrtechnisch seitdem ein
bisschen was getan hat das Thema hatten
wir ja auch schon einige Male in diesem
Podcast z.B wann der Notruf überhaupt
entstanden ist und das hat sich
sicherlich auch in das Virginia geändert
diesen FJ Morris hätte ich jedenfalls
nicht gerne als Chef der örtlichen
Feuerwehr später sagt der Mann wir
hätten nichts mehr ausrichten können
also es gab auch Grund sich zu beeilen
tja technisch vielleicht richtig sie
werden ja in jedem Fall zu spät gekommen
aber trotzdem mein lieber Scholli so was
willst du doch nicht vom Feuerlöscher
hören weiter im Text es tauchen übrigens
auch Gerüchte auf dass dieses späte
Eintreffen der Feuerwehr Absicht gewesen
sein könnte das ist eine von zahlreichen
Mythen und Theorien rund um den ganzen
Fall und die können wir gleich mal die
Banken sie hätten es angesichts der
logistischen Schwierigkeiten nicht
rechtzeitig schaffen können und einer
der Feuerwehrleute ist Jennys Bruder und
beide standen sich sehr nahe also bitte
nicht zu viel Verschwörungstheorie am
Morgen des 25 dezember beginnt die Suche
nach den sterblichen Überresten der fünf
vermissten Kinder auch George und die
beiden überleben den Söhne helfen mit
alle drei sind von ihren
Rettungsversuchen verletzt aber niemand
kann sie abhalten das ist schon wirklich
furchtbar die Vorstellung dass man da in
glühenden Trümmern nach den eigenen
kindergraben muss eine eine
schauen dass ich jeder Vorstellung
entzieht wir wissen natürlich nicht
genau wie sich die Hinterbliebene damals
gefühlt haben aber sicherlich kann sich
jeder ausmalen dass sie auf jeden Fall
unter Schock standen aber wir wissen
dass der Vater und seine Söhne bei der
Suche halfen vielleicht kann ich mir
vorstellen wie man auch einfach
irgendwas tun in so einer schrecklichen
Situation um das Gefühl von Kontrolle zu
bekommen und um sich nicht gleich von
der Trauer auszusetzen aber das ist
natürlich reine Spekulationen die
Jahrzehnte später sie finden keine
Spuren von Leichen und damit sind wir
nach diesem Brand mittendrin im Rätsel
um die verschwundenen Kinder der soll
das es werden noch viele Fragen zu
beantworten sein in diesem Fall z.B
warum war die Telefonleitung
durchgeschnitten was hat es mit
Feuerbällen am Himmel auf sich und
spielte ein Versicherungskaufmann eine
Rolle dieser Fall ist so umfangreich
dass er ihn in zwei Episoden erzählen
wir hoffen also wir hören uns bei Teil 2
wieder euer Stefan Fan und euer Nico